depuis le 1er janvier 2018 christine
blanchard masi empruntent
quotidiennement ce petit couloir qui
mène à son bureau de bâtonnier titulaire
d'une capacité en droit
un diplôme d'état d'un niveau équivalent
à celui du baccalauréat elle fait ses
études à la faculté de sceaux dans les
hauts-de-seine
l'avocate prête serment à paris en 1993
puis intègre le barreau de versailles
deux ans plus tard
l'amande judiciaire était pour moi une
fascination la défense aussi est un
métier qui m'attirait au plus haut point
et c'est tout naturellement oui que je
me suis dirigé vers vers ce métier qui
25 ans après toujours une passion
spécialisée dans le droit de la famille
elle est élue le 22 juin 2017 bâtonnier
de l'ordre des avocats de versailles son
mandat de deux ans se terminera fin
décembre 2019 avant elle seules deux
femmes ont accédé à cette fonction à
versailles en 1959 et en 1996 un honneur
pour christine blanchard masi c'est
comme dans tout domaine de la société la
femme à doit prouver encore plus qu'un
homme pour accéder à des fonctions de
direction
donc les herbes les avocats n'échappe
pas à cette problématique que
rencontrent les femmes mais c'est vrai
que ça a été assez dur il ya encore un
état d'esprit
assez misogyne mais dans l'ensemble j'ai
été élu de façon extrêmement confortable
des larges ce qui me donne légitimité
certaine chef des 790 avocat qui
composent le barreau de versailles son
rôle est multiple veiller à ce que
chacun respecte ses obligations en
termes de déontologie en termes de
formation s assurer que les droits des
avocats soient respectées mais aussi
gérer les litiges fait quelqu'un qui va
droit au but
un qui avance qui ne recule pas et qui
veut aller de l'avant sans arrêt moi ça
fait comme ça fait 20 ans que je suis là
donc c'est la première fois que tu as
une femme élue bâtonnier effectivement
sachant quand même que le barreau est
très féminisée sont pourtant du barreau
c'est ça me paraissait un peu normal que
en plus de ses nouvelles fonctions de
bâtonnier christine blanchard masi
continue d'exercer son métier d'avocat
indispensable selon elle pour rester en
contact avec ses confrères et les juges
une profession qui est malgré tout
stressante
ce que nous apprend un séminaire des
dauphins mais dauphin ce sont les
bâtonniers qui viennent d'être élus
pendant six mois qui suivent leurs
prédécesseurs avant la prise de fonction
et donc au séminaire des dauphins on dit
la première chose respirez soufflez ça
fait ce que je vais très souvent pour
pour reprendre mes esprits et me
concentrer plus sérieusement oui je
pratique du sport pour relâcher
durant son mandat christine blanchard
masi compte notamment mettre en place
des outils afin d'améliorer la
communication avec le grand public